we need to know what do we stand for
a good piece of evidence that the biden
administration is changing u.s policy
is with regard to one of our allies
israel you know that israel had a great
relationship with the united states
under the trump administration
it's funny because they would call trump
literally hitler
you know i'd say he was an anti-semite
worst anti-semite in history
least successful anti-zemite they named
a town for him in israel
can you imagine wow gosh what a what an
ineffective anti-semite
i think his son-in-law is an orthodox
jew right it's not very effective
so israel has a great relationship under
trump
now the question is what's that
relationship going to be like joe biden
has had a pretty good relationship with
israel back when democrats were more
moderate
but obviously joe biden is not the man
he once was
in terms of his policy views i actually
think he is the same man i think
he's not principled he licks his finger
puts it in the air figures out which way
the wind is blowing and that's what he
believes he's a total empty suit he's
just a glad handing
a typical politician if you weren't a
politician he'd be selling used cars
and the party has moved very far to the
left so therefore
the administration would appear to be
moving that way too listen to jen saki
explain the administration's view on
israel
can you please just give us a broad
sense of what the administration is
trying to achieve in the middle east
for example does the administration
still consider the the saudis and the
israelis important allies
uh well uh you know again i think we
uh there are ongoing processes and
internal interagency processes
one that we i think confirmed an
interagency meeting just last week to
discuss
a range of issues in the middle east um
where we've only been here three and a
half weeks
and i think i'm gonna let those policy
processes see themselves through before
we give kind of a
complete lay down of what our national
security approaches will be to a range
of issues
this woman is so bad at her job it's
just she
i get that part of her job is dodging
questions so i'm not knocking her for
that but she's just
she's just bad at ducking questions like
she does
ah man t.j ducklow if he weren't if he
weren't such a derelict on those phone
calls he really
would have had a great opportunity here
so
question you know are you going to keep
up these policies with israel don't
forget we were told by
john kerry who's in the biden
administration by other prominent
democrats
you'll never get any peace with israel
and other muslim nations
if you don't first deal with the
palestinian question it can't happen
you know john kerry thurston hello iii
said this
verbatim and then what does trump do he
ignores the palestinian question
he just starts dealing with these
individual nations he signs record peace
deals with israel and a lot of muslim
nations
so you know is biden going to keep this
up obviously biden's not going to keep
this up because the way that
that the trump administration secured
these kind of deals was in large part
leaning on saudi arabia against iran
ripping up the iran nuclear deal and
that sort of thing
right and by working with saudi arabia
they were able to secure a lot of these
deals
but the biden administration and the
democrats
don't like saudi arabia they like iran
right you kind of got to pick a side
when you're talking about saudi and iran
the democrats think that their path to
success is to suck up to iran
so obviously they're not going to pursue
the same policy with regard to israel or
the middle east
and gensock he can't say that yet but
that's you know that's going to be a
fundamental reordering of american
policy to the middle east
this is going to be true in china this
is going to be true
all over the way this is going to be
true with our policies in europe even
and with russia is
you're going to have an upending of this
foreign policy it's too bad because
trump
especially as a foreign policy president
is far and away the the best of my
lifetime probably the
certainly the best since reagan and who
you know maybe even uh
maybe he rivals reagan too maybe goes
back even further
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you